what you do is you take the plate and
you slowly lick it off
dj
don't let anything stop you hey everyone
it's me jasmine and today we have a very
special guest i'm larum from tasty uk
it's an awesome channel y'all should go
check it out today we are swapping our
favorite snack i'm excited good you
should be a very good taste
ready for the first snack i am indeed
you better like these what is it nuts
they're gummy clusters usually it's a
nerd's rope it's like very long they
didn't have them in the store today
because they were just that popular so
it's a sweet oh yeah this is candy okay
we call them sweets we're not candy oh
but yeah i've never heard of nerds these
are the perfect snacks for like when you
go to the movies i usually only eat it
if it's an action movie if it's too loud
to eat i thought you meant like the
sugar gets you like hyped up for the
action movie always always
so i have got england's finest cherry
bakewell tarts for what i love with
these you know they're like fake
cherries maraschino cherries that's my
favorite the packaging has been a bit
messed up from my flight this is a tea
time classic it's as british as you get
i need you to try mine first i'm ready
to nerd out oh they're a lot smaller
than i imagine
he loves it yeah
so what are the nerds the nerds are
little things yeah i prefer the chubby
center i'm not a fan of the nerds oh
would i want to watch an action movie
please yes i see it because you kind of
like chew and you're like watching yeah
that was a weird face i just pulled back
you're going to go for the bakewell
tarts i must the tea time classic you
say cheers
right it's really good i personally love
a maraschino cherry i would totally have
this with teeth this is a perfect tea
time snack i think i would keep my own
snack i would not swap well then neither
would i
can i just have both
oh what is this
this my friend is a curly wurly
a curly whirly it needs no introduction
it is just a beautiful piece of
chocolate this you could do at the
movies with some popcorn maybe a bit
curly early in the popcorn
hi you've brought me popcorn have kettle
corn kettle corn i'm a big fan of sweet
and salty yeah
you might have this one do you have
trader joe's no what's it that's like a
farmer's market type thing right should
we swap yes all right i'm ready for my
curly wheelie
wow please enjoy one with me okay let's
do it look how curly and whirly it is
look at that that's a that's a curly
hurley
what
that's how you eat a curly word is that
really how you eat no no
this is a flattened rolo it's really
good kettle corn
aka popcorn i think you guys have just
called popcorn kettle corn
no that's popcorn sugar on popcorn is
petal corn that's pretty good you've
just renamed popcorn not all popcorn has
sugar on it but the popcorn with sugar
on it is called kettle corn there's just
flavors to popcorn final thoughts this
is a hundred percent kettle corn and i
will be keeping my snacks give me my
curly welding back then next snack ready
i'm worried three two one
what is that is that a boiled egg sorry
i'm just in shock that you've brought me
a boiled egg with
soy sauce i've brought you a teres
chocolate orange which is a chocolate
orange it's self-explanatory who's terry
you'd have it with some kettle corn yeah
that's right see i'm learning i'm
learning the ways you got to unwrap it
and then give it a little whack on the
head and then the slices should fall out
i have brought this snack it is a
childhood snack that i had growing up i
can understand your reaction because i
would bring it to school and the kids
would also say what the heck is that
here's your egg thank you do you like
soy sauce i mean you've bought it so i
might as well i pour it over i'll do the
same thing with mine oh so you're gonna
join me we're gonna wouldn't miss out on
this i'm pretty certain i know how this
is gonna taste wait there's a process
you're going to cut it in half you're
going to separate the yolk from the
whites so now we're going to eat the
whites
that's exactly what i imagined it to be
so good right i'm not sure about the
process of it though that's confusing
trust the process trust the process push
it to the center of the soy sauce and
you're just gonna smash you want it to
be pasty and make sure to soak up all
the soy sauce i can't believe i'm doing
this on video one time my mom walked
into me doing it's embarrassing what you
do is you take the plate and you slowly
lick it off
numb
don't let anything stop you it's not
terrible it's good i don't understand
that method of eating it
when in rome
now for dessert so unfoil it whoa oh so
you didn't need to whack it no bonk
necessary give it a little bunk
give it something there you go wow it's
so pretty shall we cheers cheers
mmm
this is so good would i switch snacks
well it's hard to say because that was
savory and this is sweet
no
sorry to be brutally honest i'd be down
to squat but mine's really good okay
next snap next okay oh flaming hot i'm
seeing i know you said you weren't good
with spice earlier so good luck these
are funyuns they are onion rings and
coated in flamin hot dust i've heard of
onions i'd like to try it do they taste
of onion oh very these are my go-to
snack period a battle of the crisps
these are hula hoops and there's a
really fun way of eating these as well
they're barbecue flavors you're gonna
make me put them on my fingers huh yes
oh you know what
these all right ladies first okay
they're so cute they're cute right now
you can get different flavors but these
are my favorite cheers and then just
yeah
hmm
i like them they're really good yeah
they taste like beef yeah it's beef
barbecue though oh boom right should i
try your funyuns now that's a potent
smell
oh it's spicy too spicy no oh wait let's
cook it in a bit i'd rather a hulu
personally i'd rather a bunion well
let's swap back then give me give me
lips i think mine are more fun than
yours
wow let's see what the last one is
final snack let's do it
oh
that looks yummy i like ritz oh yeah i'm
happy i'm happy with this so these are
penguins it's a chocolate biscuit i used
to have my packed lunch when i was a
young boy
and the best part of this is it's got a
little joke written inside kind of like
a christmas cracker you pop it open i
have rich toasted chips in the sour
cream and onion flavor this is so
underrated that sounds really good
actually this is one of my favorite
snacks to bring when i go to the
amusement park so i'd like you to
channel that energy oh you've got a gift
for me you can wear these and eat it
amazing all right that's what all right
you go first and read us that joke who
is a penguin's favorite family member i
don't know antarctica
[Laughter]
would you like to enjoy one with me
cheers cheers
it's really good it's exactly what i
thought it would be it tastes like two
milk chocolate biscuits with a thicker
milk chocolate cream in between you
ready to try this rich yes
i am
well quite like oniony i see what you
mean about the amusement park i see
myself i think we need to photoshop you
into the parks
i think i would swap these you know
i like them you like very oniony things
i can't let go of the ritz i can't but i
would love to eat these so you would
swap one you would swap i would swap and
you would swap yeah we're swapping that
was a lot of fun lyra a lot of fun
thanks for having me you brought a lot
of really delicious snacks i will say
likewise so i think next time we should
just bring all the snacks together we
don't need to choose which ones better
we just eat everything i agree all right
guys thanks so much for watching if you
enjoyed this snack swap head to tasty
uk's youtube channel where amy and merle
are also swapping snacks bye guys
see ya
you